[Music]
and radioactive post news submit it by
happy gilmore HBO's new series share
novel is how you say that Chernobyl oh
there you go whole house is fired
tourism but people are questioning the
photos taken there
wait there's tourism in Chernobyl Oh
what it's pretty crazy
okay back in the day they had you know
like what happened in Japan with the
nuclear facility [ __ ] up that
happened in Chernobyl that's a city
where is it Ukraine so they had a
nuclear fallout and in the whole city
had to be evacuated oh my god wait I
think I'm gonna mow and the influencers
are taking pictures with it or like
they're visiting the site and they're
taking photos and some people like they
kind of like twisted the pose I love
that the closest you come to a
historical event is if influencers are
there in that picture what I'm talking
about I saw this both Chrissy Teigen
posted because M she tweeted a and there
was this girl showing her but when the
site Alexei Chernobyl photo shoots great
like Justin Bieber going Anne Frank's
house and he's signed the guestbook and
he's like I think if she was around
today she would have been a belieber
yeah remember that this was the first
tweet that brought attention to this
whole thing so it says oh yeah meanwhile
in Chernobyl what Instagram influencers
flocking to the site of the disaster and
these are the posts so this one ignore
that is that and then that and then that
and then that what up so it's perfect
she had a nice body though yeah and then
maybe we start trying to say that our
bodies nuclear it's mom there's a time
and place part there's a time in place
for years 21 yeah it's a half-life thing
yeah how do you say Chernobyl Chernobyl
Chernobyl okay so
better it sounds like it an influencer
campaign bailed like it's sure but it's
like Russian or some [ __ ] thank you so
the showrunner of the new HBO series
called Chernobyl he commented on this
hurry was a good show it's wonderful
that the Chernobyl HBO has inspire
inspired a wave of tourism to the zone
of exclusion but yes I've seen the
photos going around if you visit please
remember that a terrible tragedy
occurred there comport yourselves with
respect for all who suffered and
sacrificed that's like going to the
Holocaust caps and being in a [ __ ]
bikini photo shoot yes it is for sure
that looks really really really bad but
to clarify three out of the four photos
that were posted in that tweet they're
not even influencers it's just people
people they're trying to make it that's
why they're doing something shocking
this photo
it's not even recent it was posted many
many years ago so people are trying to
make it more dramatic than what did it
just say boobs what's on the calculator
what I don't get it's a guy it's a
Geiger counter that's what it's called
yeah so to measure the actual radiation
so that place is in a place of tourism
yeah like it's not like you can go
through it anyway oh yes it is it like
people do or they do have you wait until
I go through it there are tours that you
can take that where can you get some
Chernobyl merch but it became so
recently their mascots a baby with three
legs yeah so that one influencer I
mentioned was this photo ID by those
disappoint wearing like this hardhat
thing and so she actually wrote like a
really nice caption about like
reflecting on the disaster that happened
yeah that doesn't sound like that that
that one right there isn't like oh my
god you're [ __ ] influencer yeah I
thought that was cool you're sharing
America the naked one was gonna make the
ones [ __ ] up and she she has like a
thousand followers or some she's trying
to grow she is trying to grow showing
her but yeah yeah and so now
probably has like 10,000 she probably
doesn't do it I've seen so many I mean
not to digress let's do it let's digress
I've seen so many girls to close their
butt and don't even got that many
followers so I'm like yeah it's so weird
there's not like with really
professional pictures like they should
have like a million and it's only like
300 people I mean I'm not putting the
girls who show their butt down like you
do you girl you know God Kim but I'm
showing her about the cynical followers
all right see but they think it does
obviously yeah they do think it does
because it's the easy way well you know
what it is when they post that [ __ ] for
four years it's like maybe your butt's
not that good they don't think that yeah
I'm just like maybe tomorrow yeah maybe
tomorrow a different angle yeah you know
shaking looking [ __ ] exactly but
anyway so that's kind of a little it's
done though that's happening how can you
so you go to Chernobyl you you like walk
around take pictures buy souvenirs like
you buy a deformed candy bar or
something like we're you know I think
it's like seeing history happen you know
like when you go to Pearl Harbor yeah I
like going through something that's been
through a lot you know we went to it's
another really big one but Zac out was
it documented I think is that guy I
think it's that guy did that cause in
Germany right yeah yeah yeah that one
yeah we went there some pretty nuts it
was horrible doesn't it feel like the
energy feels different that you live I
there's nothing you could buy no you the
energy is insane you felt the death dead
spirits uh you just it's a very heavy
feeling obviously because you know the
history right um and then to try to put
yourself I mean you can never ever put
yourself in the position of the people
that were actually going through it but
like just to go in there and feel it and
see it firsthand you're just like [ __ ]
man yeah I hope even though people like
kind of implies a certain feel like so
there's all these fields like working
our fields and then there's walls at
border it in and along the walls are
these towers where the snipers would be
so you could just imagine what it's like
with people pointing guns at you and it
could kill all of you guys if you guys
aren't working hard enough you guys been
in the Denver Airport is that what it
feels like feel like that nope
no cuz they have [ __ ] up murals and
[ __ ] man like kept kids on fire and
stuff like as you're walking by yes
weird Denver Airport yes what's the
history behind Denver I've no idea I'm
just talking about the feeling yeah I
got that feeling walking by Denver
Airport cuz I never been to any of those
things it's nuts it's pretty nuts in
there do you guys take any photos or
vlog at all yeah we did both but we try
to do it appropriate and stay song you
didn't show your butt smiley there's
never smile Ernie for us like the
Instagram for us it's not about like
influencing people or whatever but we
know we have that for us it's like a
memoir like a memory yeah and that's
exactly when they mentioned in this
article like this one specific piece
they're talking about how like the
writers saying that they remember just
months after 9/11 happened when they
went to go visit Ground Zero with their
mom they asked her to take a photo of
them in front of the thing and it wasn't
like it wasn't to like show off like oh
yeah look I'm here it's more like damn
like I was here and this happened in
history and like this is a moment in
time that I want to remember so that's
what they're saying about what's
happening now with Instagram it's not
necessarily like you know like oh let me
take a selfie and like whatever it's
more like our memoirs type of thing it's
the body language though it can be fun
like this or even like doing this like
like it's weird definitely has to have
like its its parameters around it but
it's just like even if you're being
respectful even if you're talking about
how you're reflecting about the tragedy
that happened in that site people are
still [ __ ] on it saying like this
ain't about you yeah because a lot of
people try to use it for cloud like
remember when there was the hurricane
and all those models got [ __ ] on
because they're out there all on the
[ __ ] beach opposing and it'll like
all the [ __ ] victims I remember being
here in summer and [ __ ] it's like forget
that needs to be no give us any [ __ ]
appropriately we weren't smiling like I
didn't try to like kind of personify the
feeling that we got there but you get
grouped up with everyone because people
don't know that yeah the difference yeah
they don't know the difference so now
anyone that's doing anything like even
recently with the
France the the the northern oh yeah dude
I remember um Casey posted something or
yeah cuz I didn't post but he posted a
photo about her wedding they're like
this isn't about you but it's like no
it's you had a memory there yeah and it
hurts you exactly cuz yeah but people
can't do that any people are always
gonna be [ __ ] yeah and that's what
I was gonna say I mean how many people
are probably sitting there like well I
never I got to go so why are you posting
about it you know what I mean like it's
so funny
social media existed when Pearl Harbor
happened people would've been like this
isn't about yeah they were about the
9/11 thing to go writer they were like
if if I was born like a decade later or
something like I probably would have
posted this on Instagram too because
that's just the generation like just
that's what we do that we're doing now
the culture
well the idea too is that you can't
you're not allowed to remember something
or like talk about something that that
affected you unless you had a family
member died there person - yeah but it
affected everybody man yeah just dead
like of course those people had a
different experience than you a much
worse experience so the conclusion is
that we're okay with it I don't know if
it's done right like respectfully I
think yeah you could do whatever the
[ __ ] you want even if you're in a bikini
during a hurt so you saw that picture of
the girl with the butt and you're like
[ __ ] she's doing her thing my thing
like it's up to her yes I agree wear a
chicken costume to Ground Zero go ahead
yeah what people will judge you for it
that's what I'm saying is get prepared
for the backlash even if you're doing it
out of like because you really feel like
you want to say something out of like
just like just like how Casey posted the
picture right I mean it came from his
heart whatever but then people are still
gonna talk [ __ ] yeah anything you post
just get wrists get ready for [ __ ]
talking and it's like I'm not from
Chernobyl
I'm not even Russian why do I give a
[ __ ] you know like half the people that
talking [ __ ] on Casey's photo are you
guys in French did you grow up around
there like so I don't know yeah doesn't
even matter I don't even know why people
are talking sure the first free to mean
free expression means it goes both ways
yeah like so you can express yourself
and then people can react to it and
people want to hate then that's their
prerogative and there's a beauty to it
deal man because without this stuff we
wouldn't get to talk about Instagram
people showing their asses
I [ __ ] laugh at this [ __ ] I'm so glad
they exist yeah it gives me hope that
that that the world isn't all just bad
things it's like people take they like
to wipe on these bad things with their
shittiness but I see so much fun in it
yeah like it gives me so much laughter
that is such a have you seen it the one
with the fire this is one chick it was
like fires it literally looks like
Elly's melting and then she's sticking
her ass up and she says like pray for
fire fire yeah it's like she's like
looking and she's like this yeah and it
looks like la is straight melting you
know what though it worked because she
probably wanted us to talk about it and
people talked about it and shared it and
she probably got followers or whatever
the case I bought her bikini after yeah
just wait till the meteors coming just
wait when the meteors come in to take us
all out everyone's gonna be like posing
Oh it'll be sexy
it'll be no it'll be big enough the
meteor be big enough you probably take
picture and all the noise right like
you're holding it like right a bunch of
dudes doing pelvic so sad and [ __ ] you
know what's gonna happen but just
embrace it just like the media or you
can't do anything about it just accept
it [ __ ] it's coming for you hopefully
you can post that before I come there's
no way stopping these models on
Instagram Cheerios
[Music]
[Music]